lors de votre journal de l'afrique soit
et les bienvenus le mondial 2022 sénégal
qui se qualifient aux dépens de l'egypte
victoire arrachée aux tirs au but on ira
retrouver et sarah sakho à dakar depuis
le début de ce journal l'a tout de suite
sar à
un hélicoptère de la monusco s'est
écrasé à cet après midi dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo lui
casques bleus ont été tués l'armée
congolaise et la réunion du m23
s'accusent mutuellement d'avoir abattu
l'appareil
et puis la taxe il est vie au ghana
l'état impose cet impôt de 5 % sur tous
les paiements électroniques objectif
combler le déficit public sans faire
appel au fonds monétaire international
le sénégal a donc dominé l'egypte ce
soir les lions de la teranga s'envolant
pour leucate à une qualification
arrachée je le disais lors d'une séance
de tirs au but sarah sakho bonsoir à
vous vous êtes la correspondante de
france 24 dans la capitale sénégalaise
on entend déjà quelques bruits de klaxon
donc on imagine le soulagement et au
delà on imagine qu'on la célèbre cette
qualification ce soir à dakar
oui bonsoir lavia c'est déjà la fête ce
soir à dakar depuis en fait le coup de
sifflet de ce match les sénégalais ont
laissé exploser leur joie je me trouve à
une centaine de mètres de la place de
l'indépendance c'est vraiment le coeur
de la cité et vous l'entendez il y à des
concerts de klaxon de vuvuzelas des gens
qui sont venus avec leurs drapeaux et
toute leur famille pour célébrer
ensemble cette qualification il faut
dire que le match a été très serré
contre les égyptiens à les sénégalais
qui ont suivi la partie elles ont
vraiment souffert 120 minutes de match
et puis l'interminable série de tirs au
but avant la délivrance grâce au penalty
de sadio man et on vous l'avait dit ils
sont soulagés heureux
elle les sénégalais à qui nous avons
parlé nous ont dit leur fierté d'être
sénégalais ce soir il remercie beaucoup
sadio man et c'est vraiment l'enfant
chéri du pays et tout ça arrive moins de
deux mois après le sacre du sénégal à la
coupe d'afrique des nations la can alors
autant vous dire que le sénégal est très
fier ce soir et les regards sont déjà
tournés vers des cendres et vers le
qatar c'est la troisième qualification
du pays en coupe du monde on le sait les
équipes africaines n'ont jamais franchi
le quart de finale dans cette
compétition mais ce soir les sénégalais
ont décidé que rien ne les arrêtera et
beaucoup nous ont dit qu'il la
ramènerait la coupe du monde au sénégal
la coupe à la maison merci beaucoup à 5
en direct depuis à dacca en mission de
reconnaissance dans la région de chiang
souffrent dans le territoire de rutshuru
en république démocratique du congo un
hélicoptère de la monusco s'est écrasé
cet après midi l'armée congolaise et le
m23 s'accusent mutuellement d'avoir
abattu cet appareil propose d'écouter
porte-parole des forces armées
congolaises il répondait à justin
kalumba
ce mouvement récidiviste 1,23 vient
d'abattre dans la zone qu'ils contrôlent
l'un des deux hélicoptères de
reconnaissance de la mission des nations
unies pour la stabilisation en rdc en
cible monusco avec à son bord oui
casques bleus membres d'équipage et
observateurs des nations unies
l'hélicoptère a été abattu en pleine
mission inoffensive
d'évaluation des mouvements des
populations
causés par les attaques du m23 dans la
région
huit casques bleus tués la cause exacte
du crash n'est pas encore déterminée
voilà ce qu'a déclaré le service de
communication de l'armée pakistanaise
qui a annoncé le décès à de ses casques
bleus et sachez aussi que six
ressortissants six de ses casques bleus
sont des ressortissants pakistanais la
cause cependant de juger du bois depuis
kinshasa
la monusco confirme ce soir qu'il y
avait huit casques bleus à bord de cet
hélicoptère qui s'est crashé à changzhou
aujourd'hui parmi eux il y avait six
militaires pakistanais un militaire
serbe un militaire russe la force
onusienne ne donne pas encore le bilan
des disparitions mais vous l'avez dit
l'armée pakistanaise elle affirme que
les huit passagers de l'hélicoptère sont
tous décédés la force onusienne
explique qu'une enquête est en cours
pour déterminer les circonstances de
cette de ce crash pour rappel les
combats entre le m23 et l'armée
congolaise ont repris dans la nuit de
dimanche à lundi l'armée congolaise à
tiens me que le m23 ce groupe armé a
attaqué à plusieurs de ses positions
dans le territoire de rutshuru et les
combats ont continué dans la journée de
mardi dans plusieurs localités et
compris à bunagana pas la frontière avec
l'ouganda et l'armée ougandaise est
d'ailleurs venu soutenir l'armée
congolaise à cette frontière l'armée
congolaise affirme ce soir que le m23
ont été repoussés dans cette localité
mais la situation reste instable de
nombreux habitants ont quitté leur
village dans les zones de conflits entre
lundi et mardi et il faut il faut
signaler que le retour des m23 dans la
région est relativement récent puisqu'il
avait rendu les armes en 2013 une
majorité s'étaient repliés au rwanda et
en ouganda mais ils ont repris les
attaques en novembre dernier en majorité
contre des sites edf est à tester des
forces armées congolaises
les les m23 sont accusés par le
gouvernement congolais d'être soutenus
par l'armée rwandaise ce que ni à la
fois le rwanda et le groupe armé mp3 est
accusé par kinshasa de soutenir la
rébellion du m23 kigali a réagi après
avoir rejeté ces allégations
le rwanda a qualifié aussi de tentatives
de manipulation
les déclarations portées par l'armée
congolaise les précisions de simon vol
vaart sur place ce lundi devant la
presse le général de l'armée congolaise
ekeng et accuser directement kigali de
soutenir le groupe rebelle m23 il
affirmait détenir deux soldats rwandais
qui aurait été arrêté lundi durant les
attaques ces deux individus ont été
présentés à la télévision dans des
tenues de civils et la réponse rwandaise
ne s'est pas fait attendre le gouverneur
rwandais de la province de l'ouest
dénonce ainsi des accusations sans
fondement par voie de communiqué selon
lui ces deux hommes ne font pas partie
de l'armée rwandaise et ont été arrêtés
le mois dernier déjà pour kigali c'est
donc une tentative de manipulation de
l'opinion leur honda demande donc que
des mécanismes de vérification
bilatéraux et régionaux soit saisi de la
question dans un message vidéo c'est le
porte parole du n 23 qui a également
affirmé que le groupe ne bénéficier
d'aucune aide ni de près ni de loin d'un
quelconque pays voisins cet épisode
marque un regain de tension entre les
deux voisins dont les relations
compliquées s'étaient apaisées depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de félix tshisekedi
quand l'état reprend ses droits
plusieurs maisons situées dans la cité
ministérielle de conakry en
littéralement été détruite sur ordre des
autorités
la résidence de cellou dalein diallo a
également été rasées selon
l'administration ce bien appartient au
domaine public mais l'ancien premier
ministre affirme que son logement son
domicile et un bien privé qui lui a été
vendue par l'état en 2005 il avait
contesté ce projet et avait déposé un
recours en justice la réaction son
avocat au micro de maliki a quitté les
ajustements
vise réellement le président cellou
dalein diallo parce que il a passé
régulièrement un contrat une transaction
immobilière avec l'état guinéen on vient
de démolir les lieux alors qu'il a
engagée contre l'état une action en
revendication de propriété en cessation
de troubles et en payement de
dommages-intérêts aux agissements de
l'état de nouvelles autorités vise tout
simplement à
l'écarter à l'humide y est puisque en ce
qui concerne la magistrature suprême
edel mieux positionnés
l'armée nigériane engagés dans la traque
de raffineries illégal en quelques
semaines trois millions de litres de
pétrole brut volé ont ainsi été saisis
c'est jugé insuffisant pour les ong qui
dénoncent de leur côté une pollution de
l'air meurtrière pour les populations
reportage dans delta du niger signé
moïse gomis pour france 24
voici ce qu'il reste de cette raffinerie
est légal au milieu du chaos cette femme
est l'une des trois personnes prises en
flagrant délit sidi lloyd et le meneur
de ce raid il sonné par le gouverneur de
l'état de rivers cet élu local se sont
démunis à chaque destruction une
nouvelle raffinerie et les gars honnête
ailleurs grâce à des soutiens financiers
et logistiques
les jeunes graphein le pétrole volé ne
sont pas les personnes que nous
recherchons les propriétaires de ces
fourmis noires se dissimule dans des
hôtels de luxe de porc art où il
rencontre les acheteurs de ce carburant
est légal et pendant ce temps les jeunes
gens ici sont manipulés wild is young
boys a misé ride ici dans cet hôpital de
port harcourt ce médecin constate les
effets des émanations de gaz liées au
pétrole
cette jeune femme souffre d'asthme
depuis près de quinze ans elle fait des
crises régulières à cause de l'air
dégradé et au moins trois fois par
semaine cette patiente vient consulter
j'ai prêté serment de protéger la santé
et le bien-être de mes patients je rage
à chaque fois que je constate la
souffrance de l'un d'entre eux à cause
de maladies respiratoires générés par
autrui mes passions ne contrôle pas
l'air qu'il respire c'est la
responsabilité du gouvernement et de
l'industrie pétrolière ils doivent
respecter les normes internationales
dans le delta du niger l'espérance de
vie est de 40 ans soit 14 de moins que
la moyenne nationale
alors avec des boîtiers numériques comme
celui ci des associations écologistes
mesure le niveau de pollution
atmosphérique
ces appareils sont installés chez des
habitants volontaires à terme pour ces
militants la qualité de l'air doit
devenir une priorité dans cette région
respirer un air propre devrait-elle en
droits humains et ici il n'ya pas
d'accès à un air de qualité si vous
observez les statistiques de ces trois
dernières années la pollution de l'air a
provoqué la mort d'au moins deux
millions de personnes
depuis janvier plusieurs centaines de
raffineries sénégal ont été détruites
dans les environs de port harcourt mais
des centaines continue de fonctionner
rendant difficile une amélioration de
l'air dans cette région clé du pétrole
et gaz et j'ai rien
virements prélévements paiement par lien
électronique nous tout cela nous a
considérablement facilité la vie c'est
simple rapide et sans frais ou presque
au ghana une taxe controversée est à
l'étude elle est revenu tiré de cet
impôt doivent permettre de combler un
important déficit public c'est ce
qu'affirme le gouvernement ce qui lui
éviterait donc d'avoir recours aux
institutions internationales comme le
fmi
le renverse cher nous en dit plus
en décembre dernier les débats s'était
soldée sur une bagarre générale au
parlement ghanéen
cette fois les membres de l'opposition
ont tout simplement quitter la salle
signe que la nouvelle taxe sur les
transactions électroniques voté mardi
par la majorité continue de diviser au
ghana dans les rues de la capitale des
commerçants inquiets disent redouter
l'impact de cette mesure sur leurs
activités
cette taxe est mise en place je
n'accepterai plus les paiements mobiles
seulement du liquide depuis qu'on a
commencé à parler de cette taxe mon
commerce a souffert selon le
gouvernement ghanéen
cette nouvelle taxe d'un virgule 5 % sur
les transactions électroniques et les
paiements mobiles devrait rapporter plus
de 800 millions d'euros par an elle
pourrait permettre de partiellement
comblé un déficit public atteignant les
80 % du pib à l'origine de cette
proposition déjà formulée en novembre
avant d'être rejeté par le parlement le
ministre des finances y voit une mesure
phare pour rassurer les investisseurs et
redresser l'économie du pays
l'opposition farouche de la minorité
parlementaire à cette mesure à impacter
la confiance des investisseurs en notre
capacité à mettre en place des réformes
et à rembourser nos dettes
adopté mardi la mesure risque encore de
se heurter à la contestation populaire
selon un sondage réalisé en février près
de 75% des ghanéens ils seraient opposés
ainsi s'achève votre journal de
l'afrique merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
reste avec nous sur france 24 la
formation continue
[Musique]